monsieur le monsieur le président
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs
alors ce soir dans l'hémicycle nous
parlons toutes et tous de l'avenir
l'avenir d'un opérateur historique d'un
fleuron national et avec lui une part de
l'avenir de notre pays et je crois que
c'est là un sujet qui dépasse nos
mandats et nos opinions politiques
parce que malgré les clivages nous avons
tous à coeur d'assurer un meilleur
avenir pour notre pays pourtant j'ai
entendu beaucoup beaucoup trop de
contre-vérités et je vais essayer
je vais essayer de rectifier le tir
mesdames et messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs
vous le savez le président de la
république l'a redit au creusot le 8
décembre dernier la france a fait le
choix d'un mix électrique décarbonés
avec une part de nucléaire
aujourd'hui nous prenons massivement le
tournant des énergies renouvelables nous
faisons le choix de la résilience de la
transition vers un mix électrique plus
équilibré je m'en réjouis
c'est un choix en responsabilité pour
atteindre la neutralité carbone comme
vous n'avez voter tout en diversifiant
notre approvisionnement et pour faire de
la france une économie écologique
la france est déjà parmi les pays les
plus vertueux de la lutte contre les
changements climatiques en moyenne un
français aimé 20% de moins de gaz à
effet de serre qu'un européen 35% de
moins qu'un allemand oui notre pays
dispose d'une électricité décarbonés et
elle est le socle sur lequel nous
pouvons nous appuyer pour développer la
mobilité électrique comme la production
d'hydrogène non issus des fossiles mais
mesdames et messieurs et sénatrices les
sénateurs dire cela ne doit pas nous
empêcher de regarder vers l'avenir
cette performance française elle est le
fruit de l'histoire de choix politiques
qui ont été faits dans un contexte qui
était très différent de celui
d'aujourd'hui
le débat aura lieu en son temps sur
l'évolution du mixte de notre production
d'électricité
ce n'est pas le débat de ce soir et ce
soir j'ai entendu des craintes
que vous avez exprimées et lorsqu'on
parle d'un fleuron français il est
normal qu'il puisse exister des
interrogations des doutes des craintes
même parfois alors je vous dis à ce soir
devant vous en tant que ministre de
l'écologie et de l'énergie peut à
l'heure où nous parlons
partout en europe les concurrents d'edf
monte en puissance sur les énergies
renouvelables sur cette grande
révolution telle hydrogène comme sur
l'efficacité énergétique et le stockage
et je le dis tout net ce gouvernement
refuse que la france et edf soit
reléguée au second plan de cette
bataille faute d'avoir su adapter notre
régulation aux évolutions des marchés de
l'énergie
ce serait le prix de l'immobilisme le
prix de l' attentisme et je le refuse
il en va et vous en avez parlé de notre
souveraineté de notre rayonnement et il
en va encore une fois tout simplement de
l'avenir de notre pays
alors oui edf doit être un champion
mondial de la transition écologique et
énergétique
c'est l'engagement du gouvernement il
c'est mon engagement et c'est ce que je
suis venu rappeler ce soir atteindre
cette ambition cela demande de regarder
la réalité en face
regardez toute la réalité est qu'elle
est elle aujourd'hui les cadres de
régulation ne sont pas adaptés ils ne
permettent pas à edf de relever cette
ambition il ne lui donne pas les moyens
suffisants pour investir notamment dans
les énergies renouvelables
d'un côté s'agissant du nucléaire le
tarif historique on en a beaucoup parlé
ce soir la reine qui permet à tous les
fournisseurs d'acheter la production
nucléaire à un prix régulé a certes
rempli un rôle en permettant qui émerge
une concurrence dans la fourniture
d'électricité est que les français
puissent choisir librement leur contrat
les fournit toral les fournisseurs
alternatifs assure désormais la
commercialisation de 40% des volumes
d'électricité
mais ce n'est pas la production
absolument mais ce dispositif qui a été
créée en 2010 cela a été dit ne permet
pas de garantir correctement la
couverture des coûts et des
investissements nécessaires au
fonctionnement du parc nucléaire
existant
son prix n'a plus été révisé les puits
des 1012 et vous le savez comme moi
le nucléaire a un coût beaucoup d'entre
vous ont parlé d'un mur
d'investissements la sécurité aussi un
coût la maintenance l'entretien la
modernisation ont un coût de l'autre
côté la régulation de l'hydroélectricité
et je sais que vous y êtes très attaché
vous l'avez rappelé les uns et les
autres mesdames et messieurs et
sénatrices et sénateurs
elle est aussi dépassé notre pays doit
faire face à deux contentieux européen
et disons le clairement ça nous met dans
une situation de blocage aujourd'hui qui
empêche d'engager de nouveaux
développement et la modernisation de nos
installations qui en ont bien besoin
nous devons là aussi évolué parce qu'il
ne s'agit pas seulement d'électricité
produite par les barrages d'edf
il s'agit aussi et vous l'avez mentionné
de la gestion d'une ressource rare et
précieuse est de plus en plus précieuses
kg alors mesdames et messieurs les
sénatrices et sénateurs oui c'est exact
ce gouvernement a engagé une réflexion
est ouvert une discussion avec vole
celles en lien étroit avec l'entreprise
est pourquoi pour donner à edf tous les
moyens d'assumer son rôle dans la
transition de notre pays
très concrètement cela veut dire d'abord
garantir le financement du parc
nucléaire existant et donc réformer les
conditions de vente de sa production
oui je crois qu edf doit être rémunéré à
hauteur des coûts qu'elle supporte
d'ailleurs monsieur c'est nature gaie le
monsieur le sénateur gay que j'ai écouté
avec attention et que je n'ai pas
interrompu le projet de régulation du
nucléaire que nous portons vise
précisément à garantir la couverture des
coûts et la rémunération du parc
nucléaire et ce quelles que soient les
évolutions de prix sur les marchés ce
qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
ce serait une garantie très forte
inédite à cette échelle en europe qui
assurerait à edf le fait de disposer des
ressources financières suffisantes pour
faire face aux dépenses liées à
l'exploitation du parc existant y
compris le remboursement de la dette qui
est attaché oui les consommateurs
français doivent être protégés contre
les variations imprévisibles des prix de
gros avec un prix de l'énergie nucléaire
existant stable et prévisible ne
fluctuent en pas au gré des variations
de marché
à ce titre je veux rassurer madame la
sénatrice saint pée l'évolution de
l'organisation du groupe n'aura aucun
impact sur l'existence des tarifs
réglementés
et la péréquation ne sera pas remise en
cause c'est avec ces deux principes au
coeur que nous poursuivons la discussion
de même nous entendons mettre un terme
au contentieux sur les concessions
hydrauliques d'edf car notre objectif
est simple conforter le parc hydraulique
en permettant à edf de conserver la
gestion de ces concessions sans mise en
concurrence
alors vous le voyez nous ne cachons rien
rien aux ambitions et rien de notre
exigence
bien sûr certains voudraient faire
croire que la discrétion qui préside à
ce type de négociations et qui préside à
tout type de négociations avec bruxelles
et 2,6 et le signe d'un complot pour je
ne sais quel résultat
mais je le dis j'ai le dis et je le
redis ici devant vous notre seul mandat
notre unique exigence est d'aboutir à
cette évolution majeure de la régulation
parce qu'elle est en faveur d'edf de la
protection du consommateur et de notre
politique énergétique
parce que notre pays a tout à y gagner
et comme nous n'avons rien à cacher je
le dis avec la plus grande clarté
oui ces évolutions si nous arrivons à un
accord nécessiteront une modification de
certaines des structures internes du
groupe
la commission sera attentive à la
manière dans les activités de production
réguler seront organisées par rapport
aux autres activités du groupe
mais laissez-moi être clair jusqu'au
bout car ce soir
comme depuis le début de ce projet trois
contrevérités continue à être professé
non nous n'allons pas dépenser edf comme
vous le présente comme vous le prétendez
non nous n'allons pas non plus
démanteler le groupe et non et oui
évidemment nous préserverons le statut
des salariés auxquels je veux ce soir
rendre hommage et que je veux rassurer
ceux dont ce dont nous parlons ce soir
c'est bien de doter edf d'une structure
à même de pérenniser ses activités
d'accroître ses perspectives de
développement et de financer sa
croissance et pour assurer le
financement des parc nucléaire et
hydroélectrique tout en constituant un
grand
champion des nouveaux métiers de la
transition alors avec ce projet les
parcours professionnels des personnels
d'edf seront préservés le statut des
industries électrique et gazière sera
préservée et l'ensemble des activités
restera détenu très majoritairement par
edf dans le cadre d'un groupe public est
intègre et je rappelle que
l'actionnariat privé existe déjà dans
l'edf
la question est et on pourra l'envisager
c'est par exemple de mettre des plafonds
et ça ça fera partie du débat parce que
oui mesdames les sénatrices et messieurs
les sénateurs
edf est une entreprise publique et le
restera cela fait partie de l'adn du
groupe et même je crois d'une phare de
l'adn français mais nous ne sommes qu'au
début de ce chantier
à ce stade nous ne sommes pas encore
parvenus à un accord global avec la
commission européenne et les échanges se
poursuivent cela prend du temps mais
c'est aussi parce que le gouvernement
tient bon sur les points essentiels du
projet et parce qu'on veut qu'il soit
solide et si cette négociation ouvre le
champ des possibles je le dis devant
vous jamais elle ne préemptera la voix
des élus de la nation et l'indispensable
discussion parlementaire sur l'avenir
d'edf avant toute réforme et je vous
confirme que cette discussion ne se fera
pas dans le cadre d'un projet de loi
climat et résilience ou dans le cadre
d'un projet de loi 4d ce sera une
discussion spécifique sur ce sujet de
même une réorganisation ne peut se faire
qu'en des battants et en décidant dans
le cadre des instances de gouvernance du
groupe avec les partenaires sociaux
je m'y engage car je crois que ce
dialogue se débat à venir c'est beaucoup
plus qu'une obligation légale ou
politique
c'est le gage de la meilleure décision
pour le pays voilà mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs ce
que je voulais vous dire ce soir loi des
rumeurs loin des contrevérités loin des
peurs avec ce projet nous entendons
donner à edf les moyens de rester le
premier électricien bas carbone d'europe
en sécurisant le financement de son
parti historique et en dégageant les
moyens nécessaires pour devenir un
champion de la transition énergétique
nul démantèlement
nulle dépeçage nul remise en cause du
statut des salariés n'était au programme
c'est bien à assurer l'avenir de la
transition énergétique de la france que
le gouvernement travaille et vous pouvez
compter sur ma totale détermination
je vous remercie